hey youtubers is Charlie so this is
gonna be my flash episode for video a
lot of awesome stuff happened we got to
see an arrow Felicity crossover we got
to see Captain cold for the first time
and the birth of the Rogues like the
official birth of the Rogues Geoff Johns
wrote the episode the title was going
rogue so anytime they do stuff like that
you know there's gonna be some extra
comic book Easter eggs also hello any
new people I feel like a lot of new
people family this week so if you're
finding me for the first time I do flash
and DC TV show videos every week so be
sure to subscribe to get everything
careful for spoilers if you're not
caught up with the flash though so
starting with top five moments number
five the flash learns to harness the
Speed Force the games everyone telling
him he's not fast enough
Harrison wells telling him there's
things he still needs to learn all part
of a season-long training montage where
he learns how to do the really crazy
comic book things that includes stuff
like breaking into other dimensions or
traveling through time all made possible
through use of the Speed Force right now
it seems like that is a long ways off
though it's hard to tell how far they're
gonna go into the flash rebirth comic
like that's the comic they're adapting
for the storyline I do think it's gonna
do something crazy by the time we get to
the mid-season finale but he might just
run really really fast the train car
save at the end did seem like it was
teasing him going faster they're like
mental and physical components to
Flash's being able to access more of the
Speed Force so he's gonna have to jump
through some mental hoops before he can
go super super fast and he has to get
used to the daily grind of just fighting
average crime number four black adam's
diamond it's Geoff Johns so of course
we're gonna get another tease for a
major franchise they did the same thing
on Smallville Kahndaq has also been
referenced on arrow too I believe it
gets a lot of name drops but as far as I
know all the Shazam family characters
are gonna be introduced in the movies
first then we might get to see Osiris or
Mary or any of the not a list characters
in the TV shows they could also show up
on Constantine 2 just because they're
part of the supernatural DC Universe I
couldn't find any direct references to
the diamond specifically other vintage
just a precious artifact that belongs to
Black Adam I cannot wait to find out
what he's been doing this whole time
once we get to that movie and for those
that don't know the rock is playing him
so picture like a super Hulk out super
tan version of Superman if you want to
see like a really crazy version of the
rock just watch him him painting
pictured that character as black atom
number three félicité crossover they
made a lot of jokes about why she was
there but really I think she just wanted
to see how Berry was the first really
big joke was buried talking to Iris
about crazy people trolling her blog
about the red streak felicity chimes in
and suddenly we remembered that she had
the blog up on her screen in the last
episode of arrow that was irises blog so
Felicity is the crazy internet person
just like she was the crazy person that
burnt down Applied Sciences she was an
integral part of the story like she
wasn't just over for fun she became the
moral compass of the episode which is
basically what she is for Oliver she did
the same thing for Grant Gustin that she
does for Oliver which is why she told
him not to try to be such a loner their
work of a really funny full of City
moments though like whenever they need
her help and she jumps into like hacker
mode and they do that big camera swivel
around her that's basically what they do
on arrow whenever she goes into battle
mode
it's like Felicity's superhero shot like
whenever Stephen Amell puts the hood on
and the camera zooms in once you become
a superhero or a Justice League a Lister
you get your own superhero shot so it
was just hilarious to see them do it on
the flash and she even had her special
little desk in the middle there I don't
know where that came from it might be
because she'd been in town for a couple
days a lot of people were asking about
why she changed her outfit so many times
I think she just changed her outfit for
each day that she was there with the
exception of the dress all the women in
my Twitter feed were going crazy about
that dress and yes it was smoking hot
she is smoking hot we also have to talk
about that creepy moment with Harrison
wells I think when he said he was
expecting great things from her
he just obviously knew her future
because he's from the future but I think
he was just talking about the amazing
things that she would go on to do with
team arrow I don't think he was
specifically pointing to anything that's
gonna happen this season number two meet
Leonard snart aka
Captain Cold probably gonna go down as
the number two all-time best villain in
flash history not the most powerful but
definitely the most interesting or one
of the most interesting it explains why
they picked a really big actor like
Wentworth Miller to play him they just
need someone who can be a complicated
villain like Harrison wells another
great example of a very complicated
character in case you missed it they
pretty much breeze over his entire back
story in the comics
had a dirty cop her father used to beat
him and his sister who actually might
appear on the show at some point his
sister that is I think his father's
actually in iron Heights right now I
think they said all the trauma just
drove him to a life of crime but it's
his encounter with the flash in this
episode that inspires him to become the
person Cisco
appropriately names Captain Cold so in a
way the flash is responsible for
creating Captain Cold the flash and
Cisco Cisco gave him the gun did you
catch his reaction when Cisco called him
that to his face it was priceless
I feel like the episode did a really
good job of showing how you can be
responsible for creating your own
villains
if Cisco hadn't made the gun in Grant
Gustin hadn't saved that armored car
captain Colt would have never been born
Leonard snart would have just gone on
robbing banks look he wouldn't become
the future supervillain that we know him
as I've said it before but the Flash's
life you know whenever you zoom out the
scale is a big causality loop something
very specific happened to turn him into
the flash it wasn't by random chance and
it wasn't something that would have
happened naturally without external
intervention like Harrison wells caused
the big accident on purpose it'll all
make sense by the end of the season
but think about it this way you know if
time is a loop I know that some people
talk about time being a river there are
a lot of different ways to talk about
time but in the flash it's all about the
loop one real small thing that I picked
up that might have been a tease is that
Cisco talked about creating the gun
because he thought Barry might turn out
to be evil so he created the gun to
fight someone who had flash powers we
know about an evil flash when he does
show himself they might have to get
captain colds help to stop him because
as far as we know there's only one gun
like that if you haven't read the comics
captain Cole has always been something
of a neutral character so there is
potential that he could help Grant
Gustin out if it served his purpose
which leads me to my number one moment
Captain Cold forms the Rogues if the
title of the episode weren't teaser
enough the same man who brought him the
cold gun brought him the heat gun make
the character at the end is the real
name of the super villain heatwave just
tried to guess what his ability is I
like the way they tease the idea of
central city and Keystone City being a
rogues playground it just means they're
gonna start having a lot more fun now
now that they've upped their game so to
speak expect to see the Rogues at least
a couple more times this season
but let me know what was your favorite
moment from the episode and while you
think about that here are some of the
big Easter eggs that I spotted I already
mentioned Canada can black Adam but you
know huge Easter Egg right there
and it's not so much of an easter egg
but something to watch out for is the
colors that Felicity wears like all our
outfits they're always chosen very
carefully it's like they're trying to
inception you into thinking about
specific people and sometimes they're
just like a barometer for everyone's
emotions in the room like when things
are really chill she wears more neutral
colors or when she first showed up in
bright colors with the streaks it looked
more like the flash like her outfit was
trying to say I am so excited to talk to
you about your big secret so when she
shows back up on arrow just pay
attention to what she's wearing and what
it might say about what's going on in
the scene moving along there's the holla
heroes in the Central City Museum in the
comics this ended up being the flash
museum although I think the flash museum
ended up being in Keystone City that
person that made the phone call is
actually the person in the comics who
becomes the curator that flash museum
captain Cole talking about the motorcar
diner that's a place from the comics
when they were playing trivia at the
coffee shop the host was named Oswald
Loomis in the comics
that's the prankster he's also appeared
in the Superman comics one of the groups
on the board is named the jailbirds I
thought that might be a prison-break
joke just since so many of the actors
they've cast the season or from that
show - I think I hit most of the big
Easter eggs but if you saw any that I
didn't mention just leave them below in
the comments overall I gave the episode
an A - amazing introduction for a huge
comic book character with an amazing
performance by Wentworth Miller cannot
wait to see him back along with Dominic
Purcell he's that character at the end
playing heatwave I don't know which
episode he's gonna show up in I think
it's gonna be somewhere after the middle
of the season Felicity with team flash
totally amazing you get the sense that
she would totally fit in with their team
like she's one of them
but it's Oliver who needs her the most
so she's always gonna be loyal to him
first really the only thing that didn't
click for me was the really
relationshipy stuff like Eddie with
detective West I love that they had that
funny bro moment but I feel like we need
to get to know Eddie more before we warm
up to him he still seems like a real
mystery as the romantic foil for Grant
Gustin you're automatically programmed
to hate him add to that if you're a
comic book fan you're kind of sitting on
the edge of your chair every week just
waiting
for him to snap the Irish character is
also still a little bit of a mystery I
just don't feel comfortable with her yet
I think it's because she's not inside
the group she's one of the only main
characters who does not know who Grant
Gustin is so it's a little bit
frustrating that might be why Felicity
is so much more fun just because she got
to be on the inside from the start she
pretty much figured out what Oliver was
doing on her own before he ever told her
so maybe iris will do the same thing but
I feel like keeping her ignorant for too
long will just get really boring
especially for comic book readers that
aside it was a great episode great
rogue episode they haven't been
confirmed for season two but the CW did
just announce that the first episode of
the flash was like the highest-rated
premiere in the history of their network
so it's not a guarantee but yeah I'm
gonna call it now season two definitely
ago in case you missed it there was some
crazy Marvel phase 3 stuff that went
down this morning so I added some extra
links for all that stuff in the
description tomorrow though
Rachel Ghul is coming to arrow so be
sure to check it out you can click here
to catch up on arrow right now and click
here for last week's flash episode thank
you so much for watching let's all
high-five I'll see you guys tomorrow
you